Personalized or precision medicine is the concept of using
rich and potentially broad datasets about
an individual patient to guide optimal diagnosis and treatment decisions.
These datasets might supplement the traditional clinical record with behavioral,
environmental, socioeconomic and genomic information.
Behavioral data is largely the domain of MHealth,
a later topic in this course.
Genomic datasets are very large.
Current estimates of a single patient's genome are around
3,200 megabytes or 3.2 times tenth of a ninth base pairs.
As a result, genomic data is unwieldy for direct use in patient care.
The goal of the SMART on FHIR genomics effort is to make
genomic data usable and useful in patient care.
Among other things, it is defining
a new FHIR sequence resource that contains the most clinically relevant data,
as shown in part here.
It is also developing SMART apps that can present that data to clinicians in useful ways.
Given the complexity of genomic data,
it should not be surprising that this is perhaps
the most complex FHIR resource yet specified.
A specification includes instructions,
such as are shown here,
that explain how to document single nucleotide polymorphisms,
SNP or SNPs, the most common type of genetic variation among people.
Each SNP represents a difference in a single DNA building block called a nucleotide.
For example, here the nucleotide thymine or T in
the observed sequence replaces the nucleotide guanine or G in the reference sequence.
Here you see how to document that substitution in the sequence resource.
Apps could access FHIR genomic resources from the HRs,
from genomic data repositories or specialized sequencing systems.
The key effort for a data provider is implementation of
a SMART on FHIR genomics data adapter which
creates a binding to convert between the standard SMART on
FHIR genomics format and the provider's native format.
KRAS is an oncogene that when mutated
has the potential to cause normal cells to become cancerous.
In this early example,
Vanderbilt School of Medicine's prototype SMART precision cancer medicine act
usefully presents genomic information in real time,
comparing a cancer patient's diagnosis specific detected
gene mutations to a comparable population of cancer patients.
It should be clear to you how the sequence resource we
just discussed would support an app such-